Kimmo last night new album this week how  does it feel to be at the American Music  Awards it's such an honor to be here and  we're so thankful to have us look  forward to NCT one two seven now you  guys all chose to wear matching tux  I mean wait we all knew that we had to  dress up for the AMAs and so we just  decided to wear tuxes for this like this  amazing red carpet yeah who are we  excited to meet backstage to give me  like a little whoo if it's Taylor Swift  [Applause]  Jennifer Lopez are you guys fanciful  cardi B maybe a collaboration maybe  maybe one day we're waiting cardi we're  waiting congratulations you guys now I  noticed that as you were coming up  there's no dates with you oh not today  not today maybe next time looking for  dates to these award shows like a lover  we have n citizens out there waiting for  us we love you  you